legacies aren't shaped overnight whether
they're built on the ice behind the
bench or in the front office no two NHL
legacies are the same and we took that
idea to heart when we set out to build
NHL 17 from making that clutch save that
changes the momentum of the game to
battling for that critical inch in front
of the net during the dying seconds our
focus is to make sure we're improving
gameplay in all three zones through
deeper and more customizable experiences
in our most popular modes and by
engaging fans across all aspects of
development we're creating new
experiences that add up to our biggest
and most exciting hockey game to date
whether it's shaping the future of your
franchise making a splash in
international competition or rewriting
the record books in NHL 17 you'll get to
experience the defining moments that
only hockey can deliver no matter if
you're challenging a friend on the couch
for masterminding a team at the elite
levels of coffee
with NHL 17 you can shape your hockey
legacy where it matters to you
you